this is a production of cornell
university
thank you so much for that introduction
and thank you for inviting me
um it feels funny to be here two weeks
in a row but i'm
i'm really honored to be um asked to
uh present and um i actually realized as
i got my slides rather
ready that i presented in sips i think
last september so i
have to make sure i had to make sure i
wasn't repeating myself
um with the slides that i put together
today because i
what i had in mind was kind of an
overview
of the work that i've been involved with
for the last
uh 20 uh plus years um so i i've skipped
the first
10 in this presentation so that you're
not bored if you happen to have been
here last year
but um what i what i am
uh wanting to present on is um
you know and andy mentioned uh
agroecological approaches so
some of you may not be familiar with
this um even though there there are
people in sips who
also use an agroecological approach in
their in their
research it's both a science that grew
out of
ecology and agronomy um beginning really
in the 1930s
and a set of practices so everything
from
intercropping the use of mulch the use
of cover crops
the use of compost
botanical pesticides so sort of series
of practices
that really try to use ecological
principles
in agricultural production and a social
movement because agroecology
also tries to use a holistic approach to
food systems that
addresses the social political and
economic
and health dimensions of our food system
not just
not just production and in that sense
it's
paid attention to the needs in
particular of smallholders
farmers and try to address issues around
access to land rights to
seed and and
questions around fairness and equity in
in the food system
and so um i was involved in a
un uh report
writing a un report with a team last
year
looking at the potential for
agroecological approaches to address
uh food security and nutrition in
particular and this was commissioned by
the committee for rural
food security of the united nations um
and so
in our in our assessment of agroecology
and this
this scale here was was one
developed by uh steve gleasman who's one
of the kind of early
scientists writing about agroecological
approaches um
sort of early transitions using an
agroecological approach
you might be substituting synthetic
fertilizer with organic
fertilizer for example and then
as you kind of transition into a more
holistic
agroecological system you start to
redesign
at a farm level uh to make it uh
sort of following these ecological
principles but then as you
really try to transition the the food
system you're
addressing some of these political and
social dimensions
and um economic dimensions the food
system
so we came up with these 13 principles
that
uh drew from the scientific literature
on
what agroecology is about but also drew
from the social movements who've been
advocating for this approach to
addressing
our food system and to really transform
our food system to make it
um more environmentally friendly and
more
socially and socially equitable
and uh economically viable for
smallholder farmers
and at the center you see this
co-creation of knowledge as being a
really
important feature of agroecology that
makes it change from
really uh sort of field level changes to
transitioning the food system more
broadly um so on the on the bottom level
you see many of the things that may be
very
uh familiar in the crop and soil
sciences
things like synergies between you know
plants and animals
uh within your farming system enhancing
biodiversity
uh reducing reliance on external inputs
particularly those are that are fossil
fuel based
um enhancing soil health ensuring animal
health
but then as you move into this higher uh
higher level transition because you're
transitioning a broader
system you're paying attention to social
values and
and paying attention to diets and health
you're
ensuring economic diversification you're
trying to ensure that people have a say
in the food system so participation is
sort of
food democracy if you will and then
who has rights and control over land and
natural resources
water seeds land is there
fairness and equity in the food system
at multiple levels
and is there greater connectivity
between producers and consumers so
reconnecting
the uh producer consumer links
in the food system so attention to local
markets
uh for example local and regional
markets so this is um
uh i i introduced this and now i'm going
to talk about
the work that i've been involved with in
malawi and some of the different
ways that we have tried to use this
approach and some of the findings that
we've
had um malawi for those of you
unfamiliar with it is a country in
southern africa it's land locked it
is um a maze-dominated system
with some tubers and and legumes and
tobacco is the main cash crop for
smallholder farmers some
large-scale estate production of tobacco
tea and sugarcane and about
a quarter to a third of households have
a small have have animals but it's
a mixed system and the
soils are relatively low in soil
fertility
um with about 1500
millimeters and that would range across
the country but the areas where
i've worked in around 1500 millimeters
of rainfall a year
one rainy season and um over the last 20
years a real
push but even before that a real push
for
maize production a real focus on
calories and
on mace production with the use of
fertilizer and in particular
a fertilizer subsidy program that
provided
the majority of farmers with a subsidy
for reduced
application of fertilizer and hybrid
seed
and some um promotion of compost but
real focus on on these production so
the country has uh high rates of chronic
food insecurity
and has had consistently high rates of
child
malnutrition hovering at around 40 to 50
percent of all children under 5
malnourished undernourished for their
age
and the average income is around 350 to
400 us dollars a year so very
high levels of poverty and alongside
these challenges you have high levels of
gender inequality
and high rates of hiv aids so this is a
place where
the majority of people are smallholder
farmers
and you have multiple intersecting
challenges that make it difficult to
address food security and nutrition and
it's a place where the dominant
model has been intensification with
since that with synthetic inputs for the
last
over 20 years and even before that um in
previous
um under previous regimes
governments so i've been involved in a
long-term partnership with a non-profit
organization that actually
initially was a research project uh um
run out of a a hospital and
it began with an initiative to try to
address
child stunting rates in collaboration
with the hospital
and they now have their own farmer-led
non-profit organization they have their
own pharma research and training center
and we've been doing collaborative
research together for the last 20 years
so
if you were here last year you would
have seen some of the first 10 years of
our work together and
we've done work on child feeding
practices on cultural
ideas around child nutrition
we've done a real focus on legume
intercrops for the first 10 years
and it's interdisciplinary and we've had
a lot of collaboration with other
university scientists from other
universities
in canada and germany
norway and in malawi as well
so while i'm presenting uh there's a
team behind me of people who are heavily
involved in this research
and i'll highlight some graduate student
work in particular
later on so um in
2012 we started we were able prior to
2012 to demonstrate that an
agroecological approach at a small scale
could lead to improvements in child
nutrition
and it was this work that led to this
large-scale effort
in 2012 working with 6 000 farmer
farming households in northern and
central malawi
where they were provided with a
training of about two weeks on
agroecological principles
enough seed for around a quarter of an
acre for them to test different
agroecological strategies
and also um sort of training
on gender equity uh climate change
and um child nutrition
and we then invited them to do whatever
experiments they were interested in
trying based on
what they learned and we tracked change
over time
and we tracked it through structured
surveys through agronomic data
collection
and through in-depth interviews and so
this
um is called the malawi farmer to farmer
agroecology project and it's been
uh sort of real focus of uh my work for
the last uh
we it finished after five years but
we're we're still analyzing
some of the data so farmers did a range
of experiments including
agroforestry intercropping of legumes
the use of compost
um crop diversification including
incorporation of
indigenous crops that had largely
disappeared from the landscape
the use of sort of natural pesticides
made out of plants that
farmers could produce at home um
livelihood diversification
the use of increased integration of
animals
into farming systems and then this
overall focus
on gender equity and child nutrition
and for that we had a number of
different
educational strategies that we used i'm
just wondering is the screen that you're
seeing my presenter view
or is it the big screen it's uh
it's just the presenter view racial it's
good oh marvelous
i don't know how to change that now so
i'm looking on my big screen at
the non presenter you see all my notes
that's great
um no we can't see your notes it's
normal
oh it's normal okay sorry that's what i
meant rachel yeah
it's as it should be thank you okay
so the um we uh we
tried a number of different things and
the ideas that
we came up with came from different
farmers so for example we had recipe
days where
people brought together food and
prepared meals but
i'm really encouraging men to prepare
those meals as a way to encourage men to
take more of a role in
child care and cooking we did theater
and i i'm saying we but it was really
malawi and lead
and i was um i was involved in helping
with the research component although you
can actually see me in this photograph
because i i was able to participate in
a day where there was singing and
theater around
gender issues and
and then field days and a number of
other activities small group discussions
to really focus on uh culturally
appropriate ways
uh to change gender dynamics um
and uh this is a big emphasis of of the
project so we have been
able to show significant improvements in
food security and income for households
who are using
these agroecological practices with crop
diversity in particular
being significantly
associated with improvements in food
security
after controlling for other factors that
would lead to improvements in food
security
and um we've dug into that
in more depth and this is a paper that
just came out last month
in social science and medicine where we
tried to examine
the relationship between farm diversity
so
animals and crops and dietary diversity
and we found that um an increase in both
of those things
with the intervention and uh farm
diversity had a positive effect
on um on dietary diversity and dietary
diversity is a good measure of
diet quality and is associated with
improvements in nutrition outcomes so
nutritionists care a lot about dietary
diversity dietary diversity is a measure
of
um you know in the last 24 hours or in
the last week
out of these categories of food how many
did you eat and it's a standardized
measure that we used
um and so we found a direct relationship
between an increasing production
diversity and an increase in dietary
diversity
and we used mediation analysis and this
this work was done by a phd student in
canada
moses cansanga who's who's now uh
just started a tenure track job this
year um but
um where we found this
direct relationship and mediated by
other variables such as education farm
size and wealth
so crop diversity is is in a sense a
really
simple agroecological practice but maybe
perhaps complex because it's affected by
so many other factors
but very powerful as as something to
improve dietary diversity
we also looked at you know what's the
likelihood of someone transitioning from
being in
food in secure condition and for food
insecurity we measured that with a
series of questions that's been
validated
actually developed by folks here at
cornell in the nutrition division um
and so there's nine different questions
asking about people's state of food
security and so
even though it's not a direct measure
it's considered a valid measure and it's
closely associated with nutritional
uh direct biological measures so we
uh it's called the household food
insecurity access scale and we
found that there was this relationship
between the number of agroecological
practices that people were
taking on and the likelihood that they
would transition to food security
and so the the the kinds of practices
that seemed to matter were
again crop diversity uh incorporating
residue legume residue back into the
soil so building soil
health compost again building soil
health and legume intercrops
now i would expect that these particular
practices would vary a lot by place
in malawi where food where soil
fertility
is a real constraint and where dietary
diversity is low
i think that's why you see these really
powerful impacts from these practices of
building soil health and increasing
farm diversity um we've um
really honed in on what are the
implications for labor and what are the
implications for gender
and i think we have a
in uh what i would call
um a mixture of results
um and so this is from a paper that we
published last year
while uh farmers really felt that the
labor impacts were not
high because they were largely
reallocating their labor from working on
other people's
farms when they ran out of their own
food stocks to investing more
in their own farms and get and no longer
having to work on other people's farms
during the hungry season so they didn't
see it as additional labor
nonetheless those the division of labor
it could be uneven
in households so this quote is from a
farmer who described you know with great
enthusiasm the compost that was made and
making compost for rain fed fields took
months of preparation during the dry
season so that you would have enough
compost for your
for your field and he noted that
my wife was pregnant but carrying the
compost wasn't tiresome because they're
making the compost at home
and then they're carrying it on their
heads to the field and that was some
distance and it was
it took two trips four bags um but i
i highlighted that because there is an
assumption there that the wife didn't
find it tiresome
but he's speaking on her behalf he
didn't see it as a burden
because he was very keen to see if this
had some effect and it did have some
effect
but nonetheless in some cases we found
that
women were having to make trade-offs
between looking after young children or
breastfeeding
and doing extra weeding or
extra planting that was required because
agroecology
is more labor-intensive and in some
cases
people talked about a trade-off where
they had a young infant and because of
the workload
of wanting to do exclusive breastfeeding
choosing to
to not do some of the practices because
they had limited labor
so so definitely trade-offs involved in
gender and involved in
in child care um and and sometimes
leisure as well having less leisure
available
we also were able to show however
significant changes in gender relations
from this
combination of emphasis on agroecology
but also emphasis on changes in gender
equity
and some of the changes that we saw and
here we use this
women's empowerment and agriculture
measure
some of the changes we saw were women
having more of a say over
what to grow and what to do with the
harvest and
being more actively involved in speaking
in public and sort of leadership roles
and reporting men getting more involved
in household work
and we're still working through that
that data set but that
we found encouraging we went back
last year to see are people still using
these practices and did they share these
seeds and practices with other people
and we found that
out of a sample of 600 households
90 percent were still applying compost
80
were intercropping so you know the
majority of them were still doing some
practices
but only 37 were doing agroforestry so
some more likely to continue some
practices than others
and compost making in particular they
reported as being quite labor-intensive
um uh that about 45
were sharing seeds um far fewer sharing
information so we were finding that this
kind of larger scale effort
was less effective at sharing
information around gender or
child nutrition for example we did a
follow up with 33 farmers who had
received
seeds in information and all of them
reported using
that information and seeds that they had
received so
we weren't able to do a larger scale
study this is a small
pilot project to test the you know to
look at what was happening
post intervention but we do find some
evidence of it spreading beyond the the
participants
in the intervention this is just a map
of the kind of movements of seeds and
and where they were going
um so that's kind of uh
one of the big initiatives i've been
involved in now this is a
research project that um was a four year
research project and one of my phd
students
in development sociology sydney madison
has been very actively involved in in
this
research project where we are working
with 500 households with a
pre-post and control intervention design
trying to understand in more detail some
of the social and economic factors that
were affecting
people using these methods and some of
the implications
of increased agrobiodiversity in
in rural households so a combination of
quantitative and qualitative methods and
this research project was really done
with
active farmer researchers as part of the
team of doing the interviews and doing
the analysis
so really using the participatory
research with the qualitative methods
and we saw in the course of just three
years a significant
change in crop diversity um after one
small seed distribution at the start of
the project
farmers maintained that and increased
that
crop um diversification and again
this crop diversity had significant
impacts
on food security but we also found this
connection with
social support so there was a a
relationship between uh you know sharing
the seed
um and developing social support
and reducing food insecurity so it
wasn't just a matter of
people working on their own farms but
having a kind of network of
a social network and we
explored that relationship more with our
qualitative interviews
so farmers were saying that they you
know they had reduced labor actually
from
increased crop diversity because they
had less weeding if they had more crops
on one field
and they were consuming the foods that
they ate that wasn't a surprise
but then they were saving money on food
that they would previously have
purchased and they were reinvest
in money that they would have used for
fertilizer because they were adding
compost and they were intercropping
legumes
and they were using that savings and
investing it in animals
and investing it in dry season vegetable
gardens and this would allow them to no
longer have to work on other people's
farms
so they were able to get there was a
positive cycle where that over
each growing season they were
increasingly getting improved yields
with improved soils and
um not delayed planting
because they weren't having to go and
work on other people's farms and so that
over time they're really seeing
improvements
in the central region where this project
took place
because it was in the north and the
central region um there was a drought a
severe drought
and the farmers in that year reported
their fields where they had been
investing this compost and
residue incorporation performed much
better than
their neighbors who weren't using those
practices so they were seeing this
in terms of climate change resilience as
well but in in addition they reported
that in the past they would have had to
receive
seed and food from their neighbors and
kin as which is part of kind of
social reciprocity in that in that
context in that cultural context
and now they were able to share so as
they increased their food security they
were also sharing more seed and more
food
and so this was having this sort of
widespread impact in the
in the communities where where this was
happening
so um now we're going to switch gears
to tanzania just briefly a four-year
project that was done
with um actually a nutrition phd student
here at cornell
vicki santoso as well as uh
nutritionist sarah young who was here
and is now at northwestern and actionaid
tanzania and
um university collaborators at nmaist
in tanzania a similar context of high
soil fertility soil infertility
drier region um where we were doing our
project
high levels of gender inequality high
levels of food insecurity
more livestock than in malawi and we
used a similar
methodology of some initial training
pharma to farmer training actually these
farmers traveled to malawi and
did a two-week intensive course with
colleagues in malawi
and then um peer-to-peer training on
child nutrition agroecology and
gender and in with 588 households
again this control intervention pre-post
design
and the agroecological practices that
they experimented with were crop
diversification
legume intercrop use of compost and
manure
and farmer to farmer exchanges
and over this
four year period we saw a significant
increase in crop diversity
and intercropping and we saw a
significant decline
in food insecurity or improvement in
food security
and we also measured
child and women's dietary diversity and
we saw a significant improvement in both
of those
so an improved quality of diet for
children and for
women and i i'm not showing the data
here but we also measured women's
likelihood of depression using a
standardized measure of depression
and saw a decrease in depression and we
did again mediation analysis and found
that it was
partly due to improved food security
that explained about a quarter of the
analysis but it also had to do with
perceived improvement in gender
relations particularly
around men helping more with household
tasks we
measured a reported 30-minute increase
in men helping with household tasks
so this and a very small
change in women having a little bit more
say in how
income was spent um and we had a lot of
um preliminary work in this project on
gender dynamics in the household um so
this um sort of demonstrates uh the
implications for mental well-being um
which in a sense is not surprising that
if your food security is improved and
you have
more equitable workload that that can
make you
less likely to be depressed but it's not
something that's often studied um
in at least not in in
southern african rural households as far
as i'm aware
so one of the current projects that i am
leading
is funded by the nsf
and belmont forum and it's in
collaboration with
folks in germany
at the university of woodsburg norway um
canada university of western ontario and
malawi um
luana as well as sfhc and in this
project we're really trying to
understand we're working with households
that we begin working with with mafa and
we're trying to see
if there's any impact on wild
biodiversity birds
insects bats
from uh the use of these agroecological
practices and we're doing it in
collaboration with farmers who are
learning of
how to measure these kinds of
biodiversity measures and we're also
doing research on their
understanding of wild biodiversity so
we're sort of halfway through or part
way through this research project
and this is preliminary findings where
we found
evidence that we've had a reduction in
pest
maize decline as there's been an
increase
in agroecological practice adoption
at a village level um which we think is
exciting this is
um this analysis is led by aaron iverson
who actually was here on a postdoc for a
number of years
um and is now at um uh
an uh he's in northern new york
i think st lawrence university um and uh
we also have looked at the implications
of agroecological practices in terms of
forest restoration
and this work is led by a phd student at
the university of western ontario
uh daniel pianbara and
um he has done this really interesting
research where
he's interviewed farmers about their
perceptions of
what's driving local deforestation
deforestation rates are very high in
malawi
and done participatory gis mapping
of fallow areas and then non-fallow
cropped
areas and then sort of also oral
histories of how those lands have been
managed over several years
and so he's found
that not surprisingly
agriculture is a driver of deforestation
but so is tobacco cultivation in
particular
because of the need for cutting wood for
flu cured tobacco and burning wood for
construction those are some of the
drivers as well as charcoal production
but he's found this is with a small a
small
sample of 24 uh farms but he's found a
significant relationship between
agroecological practicing farms and an
increase in land
set aside for fallow and this is
um uh uh
using uh gis mapping
to to um look at the difference in area
so this is a
24 farms over five years whether they
were in fallow
the green or cultivated yellow and found
a significant difference between
agroecology practicing farmers having
more land put into fallow
and less land cultivated over a
five-year period
and some of the structural factors that
have fostered deforestation
are local and national politics
around bylaws and and
forest management but also rising
poverty and unemployment that lead to
sort of high demand for charcoal and
urban areas and a
market opportunity so agroecology is
only part of the solution i think is
part of what we're trying to say in this
paper um you know it's not just
it's not you changing land practices at
a farm level is not going to reduce that
entirely but some really interesting
findings nonetheless
and then he's also led this study
looking at
the evidence that agroecological methods
improve crop health and meals this is a
paper under review where
he used this um leaf
area index as a way to look at um
whether it uh uh you had improved crop
health
um from uh farms using agroecological
practices and he
looked at um this is leaf area index and
days after planting and found a
significant difference between
um uh agroecological
farm farmers leaf area index versus
non-agricultural farmers and
these are some of the practices that
they used so using
plant extracts instead of pesticides and
using the newer application
this is just that's the fancy
planet scope data don't ask me more
about it because i
can't tell you this is again daniel
piepembara's um
paper um
so just um and i think i will have time
for questions
yes um so just to conclude um our work
over the last
20 years has really shown that
agroecological approaches can lead to
improv
significant improvements in food
security household well-being
nutrition and increase in sustainable
land management
methods in malawi and tanzania and this
combination of
participatory pharma to farmer methods
where farmers aren't given sort of
one input but they're given a range of
options and
training on principles and then they
choose what they want to test
and then combining it with attention to
social equity
particularly if you're interested in
nutritional outcomes
which has been a big emphasis in our
work so really
attention to social equity within
households but also
between scientists and farmers you know
ensuring that farmers
have you know the full picture of what
we're doing and are actively engaged in
the research has been a big
emphasis in our work um and there's a
lot
more research that can be done trying to
understand some of these dynamics and
trying to understand some of the impacts
uh so looking at wild biodiversity that
question is still
unanswered really we're it's underway uh
trying to understand more about
labor impacts um but
to ensure long-term resilience for
smallholder households in malawi and
tanzania and more broadly
there's a need to address broader social
inequalities so
questions of land access seed
access to seeds climate change impacts
and building local economies i haven't
presented on any of those
today i could give a different lecture
another day um but since this is a soil
crop
some seminar i focused on soils and
crops more but
these factors are very real um
barriers and constraints to kind of
scaling out
uh approaches more broadly and
just to acknowledge the many
collaborators that i've worked with over
the years and that have funded this
research so i look forward to some
questions
you so much rachel that was great um so
we have a big crew today so
without further ado why don't we get to
it um
the floor is open so uh anyone who would
like to ask a question
either raise your hand or if nobody's
talking just chime in
rachel uh thinking about that uh work
that you did in malawi where you
described the fir
diversification of the types of crops
could you give a a few examples maybe
the top five
crops other than maize that that
diversification
involved sure uh so initially
legumes so ground nuts pigeon pea
common beans and then
indigenous grains finger millet
sorghum and also
tubers so sweet potato which you can eat
the leaves and the
and the root for example so those are
some of the top
the top hits good thank you that's
that's helpful
we talked about the
soil fertility being pretty limiting
factor in the land
numbers that you showed at the end even
with the agroecological
practices they're still only hitting
about a third of what
i probably want to see so that suggests
that you're still
very low in
infertility do you see that going
further
with more more of these practices
yeah i think you would need more um
support to really hone in on improving
soil fertility
um you know we're working with
local resources that are available to
farmers so
um those vary of course um
and so i think agroforestry there's been
quite a lot of research in malawi that
has shown it to be quite effective at
improving soil fertility but
that requires more um
financial resources that we had
available for example to
distribute that's not something that
farmers can do easily on their own
they need more support so yeah i think
like
legumes seem to be more like this
five year term uh tool
for that in in many systems so i don't
know whether that applies to this one
also that you said they were burying
legumes which seems like a very helpful
practice
yeah so i i think legumes are so
critical
and that's really where we started and
pigeon pea is
a great um uh sort of in-between crop
because it's semi-perennial you can grow
it for
five years it's got deeper roots it's
pulling nutrients from deeper in the
system there's some research done by sig
snap and others that show there's
some chemical interaction that um make
more phosphorus available for other
crops when phosphorus is when
pgp has grown yeah so big fan of pigeon
pea
there needs to be more work on varietal
uh varieties of pigeon pea because some
pigeon peas
are shorter term and more
more prone to pest damage and that's
actually
where our farms for biodiversity project
arose because of the
high numbers of costs so we're looking
for different strategies for farmers to
use
uh for managing pests um to really
kind of uh foster and enhance
pigeon pea production is one of our our
areas of interest so
yes i think and legumes of course vary
in what they
contribute for in terms of biomass
and you know something like common bean
isn't producing much in the way of
biomass
but something like pigeon p can produce
quite a lot of biomass there's other
legumes like tofrosia that is that that
is not
um an edible legume so it requires
farmers to set aside
some land for uh soil fertility
improvements so some farms with more
land available that's an option for them
but for
land um strapped farmers the edible
legumes
i think have a lot of potential and uh
a soil scientist would be able to give
you better numbers than i can but
i know that um sig snap i think uh
no i won't be able to pull the number
out of my head but
pigeon p intercrops can give a very
significant contribution for
improving soil fertility great
dg russiter
oh sorry i've got a newt thanks um
i'm confused always when i hear about
this acro ecology
with the integration between what i call
the agronomy
which is most of what you've been
talking about which you know is very
good
and then the social uh aims the gender
equity and all that that which is fine
also
nothing wrong with that but um do they
really have to be so tightly integrated
what i mean by that is i could think of
having
a larger scale or even a big commercial
farm
that used all these principles you're
talking about and
on the other side i could think of farm
that wasn't using it but was
you know also going for these other
principles so when did this integration
why this very tight integration between
the two concepts of
of the agronomy and and these particular
social benefits
how did that happen
i i didn't plant him i swear what a
great question
um so uh when did it happen
i think in it uh in part it happened
um with social movements it was from the
start because they were looking for
social benefits from agricultural
production
not just increased production or more
diversified production or not just
environmental benefits so in latin
america for example
uh in brazil and and in mexico and other
countries where there was
um small holder organizing around
trying to ensure uh environmental and
social benefits from agriculture
there was uh from the start this linking
between
ecological production and
making sure that this benefited more
than just
uh a few um
certainly um the scientific development
of agroecology back in the 30s
was largely focused on just the marrying
of
agronomy and ecology and not paying
attention to this
a social dimension but starting i would
say around the 70s
this connection between the kind of
social side
and the political side and the um
agronomic and ecological side became
more tightly aligned and it's been
there's been a lot of scholarship and a
lot of advocacy that these
two are connected if you only have the
agronomic and ecological side then you
might have
environmental benefits to agricultural
production but you may not see any
impact in terms of
food security or health benefits or
livelihoods for small scale producers so
it's crucial that those
two get connected if you want to have a
sort of
multi-faceted
food system that that has benefits in
all of those dimensions
okay thanks uh that's clear i just think
then the title is
uh a bit misleading it seems like there
should be maybe two words or something
because as you say
uh the idea of using ecological
principles within agriculture is fine
and and that is earlier but that's very
clear thanks a lot
great any other questions
yes ma'am i have a question just
expanding on gender equity
i was hoping maybe the classes that the
males is it just the males attend or do
you also have females that attend it
and what what goes on in those courses
maybe some examples
i appreciate it
thanks thanks jeremiah um so
the classes there's there's a range of
different strategies so we've been
trying
a number it it is not easy to address
gender inequity
in the united states let alone in other
countries right so
um this isn't something that's solved
overnight and we have tried over the
last 20
20 years a number of different things
we've tried small group discussions
where we've had all men all women and
actually divided by
age and in small group discussions
facilitated by
community members and um and then coming
together in a large group and talking
about those
uh small group discussions we found that
to have some
impact we've tried these community
events
where it's both men and women and almost
in a
in a kind of celebratory almost a
performance
demonstrating you know different ways of
being together but
um with these recipe days we've
used theater where we've had different
plays which local people
perform and then discuss um
you know different issues that come up
whether it's alcoholism
or domestic violence or um
uh you know unequal division of labor
um uh so that's also been quite
effective
um so and then even peer-to-peer
uh visiting and discussion um has been
a feature so a range of different things
some some
which are sex segregated and some which
are integrated
and uh it it's you know sort of dialogue
based as a as one of the real emphasis
areas that was
that was beautiful thank you ma'am
are there more questions for rachel
if not rachel maybe i can ask you one
andy i've got a question if
sorry go ahead phil um
rachel that was a wonderful presentation
and and i was particularly taken with
your
multiple partnerships um pathways sorry
multiple pathways to food security i
thought that was a terrific
slide and and when you were talking
about that um you talked about how
um there was a change over that time
between
members of uh families working off
their own farm working for other farmers
and then
as conditions improved on the the
individual farms
ecologically and nutritionally there was
less need for
uh folks to go off their own farm and
more need of course
staying on the farm how did the social
networks change
across that period i mean i
i assume what you were getting at is
that with the rising agro-ecological
methods there was more seed and
information sharing um
was that mediated by um your project or
was that
did that sort of spring up um you know
simultaneously automatically and um yeah
what kind of social relations were there
among farmers where
folks were working you know across
different farms
previously right i mean so
previously um the more food insecure
households when they ran out of their
own food stocks would go and work on
other people's farms
sometimes for pay and sometimes just for
food
that's been a long-standing practice
there's some
special name for that um called ganyu
and it's it's um considered um
a social obligation to hire someone if
they are
short of their own food um but it also
is exploitative
um and uh previously i've done research
on that dynamic and it can be
you can imagine you have no food in your
home you're going to a neighbor who's
better off and asking can i work for you
for food it's not
it's not it can be quite humiliating um
there is a lot of seed sharing uh
collectively
um informally and reciprocity is a very
important
social norm in malawi and uh but not so
much information sharing
so i would say certainly our
intervention fostered more
information sharing between farmers we
we have found previously that there's
very little information sharing about
farming
and in fact one study we did found only
10 percent of households
talked about farming even between
husbands and wives uh so
there isn't a tradition of a lot of
information sharing
seed sharing yes um and so i think that
the there was a lot of emphasis in the
intervention around farmers
talking to other farmers and sharing
information um
but then what they also talked about
in those interviews is how they they
went from being kind of a
beggar essentially to being someone who
could be very
generous and that this you know
facilitated more
social networks for them so that was
something that they really
that was something very important to
them that they strongly appreciated
um and increased their social networks
thanks and i think also
just on that point they there's a big
emphasis in our work on
experimentation that farmers do their
own experiments and i think that
was very empowering for farmers to think
about them doing their own experiments
they
try out their own thing and they talked
about how they were
encouraged by the fact that it was a
fellow poor farmers who were also using
these methods
and that it wasn't just the well-off
farmer who was using these methods so
that was important too good
um i have a question sorry i can't turn
my camera on i'm having some
broadband issues but um a little bit of
a departure from mr mcmichael's question
but um kind of building off jeremiah's
i was wondering if you could explain a
little bit more what the
um child nutrition education looked like
and then also what some of your
measurements were for
um increased nutrition and
um because i just have so many questions
about the nutrition related aspect of
things i was wondering if
um given the initial lack of diversity
and diet that you were talking about if
there are any widespread
nutrient deficiencies that are present
in the area that
were worked on uh specifically in
combating
so i'll start with that one first there
are
micronutrient deficiencies um iron is
a big one um vitamin a um we have not
measured either of those things um
we previously did measure child growth
um but that's quite and in tanzania in
the tanzania project we also measured
child growth so
height and weight and arm circumference
but um we haven't done that in malawi
for
over a decade because it's it's quite
intensive and
so my malawian colleagues were not keen
to include that as a measure if we
didn't have to so our main measure of
child nutrition in malawi has been
dietary diversity as well as different
child feeding practices
um and for the mafa project we
only measured child dietary diversity we
didn't
we didn't um we didn't go into
more depth than that um in tanzania we
have measured
it's it's a an index of
child feeding practices for young
children children under the age of two
that we use
and um i don't think we've
i don't think we've found a significant
difference
in those practices except for dietary
diversity
our nutrition education we actually
developed a curriculum
that integrates nutrition with
agroecology and climate change and
gender and
then nutrition component is largely
focused on
increasing dietary diversity and
exclusive breastfeeding and water and
sanitation practices for young children
um as well as responsive feeding
but um a lot of the focus for us has
been
on exclusive breastfeeding and
dietary diversity i would say those
would be at the big areas of emphasis
um in terms of what it's looked like
it's also varied
a lot over time we have gone from doing
um house to house visits to um community
events
and theaters similarly with gender we've
used
theater for nutrition education um two
we have a two week training course that
incorporates all of those things
and we have a combination of like
hands-on activities
and theater and um small group
discussions
and things like that so it's kind of a
mixture of all those things
thank you so much there are more
questions for rachel
we're a little bit over time rachel
apologies
uh let me ask you just one quick
question for
for future discussion probably um but
the
approach that you've used has been
multi-faceted in terms of agronomic
interventions
and uh including things in crop genetics
and also very training heavy in the
sense of deep engagement with a few
number of farmers and i'm
curious if you could comment on some of
your ideas
around scaling both and maybe a triage
based approach
we all know that certain packages
practices are difficult to extend in the
near term
and that extension staff in eastern
southern africa
usually it's quite limited so i'm
curious based on what you've learned
from this deep engagement
with these farmer groups if you have
some some key insights on
how to accelerate some transformations
beyond the direct areas where you've
worked
yeah it's a big question i think i
i think it has to involve um
farmer to farmer teaching and
experimentation
because it has to be so um
agro ecosystem appropriate so i feel
like there always has to be some
component of
farmers and the social piece so farmers
finding the right
combination for their context um but
i think you know the kind of agroecology
schools that have there have been a
number of them established in latin
america which are led by
farmer organizations or social movement
organizations might be a strategy for
scaling out this approach
but with technical backstopping from
scientists working alongside those
organizations
um i don't have a lot of confidence
in um the extension system
working with this model because the
extension system
as far as i have seen it operate largely
uses this kind of tech
transfer um really you know
uh expert driven model um and sort of
input driven model
um if it were possible to
you know revert you know really overhaul
the extension system to take that
approach
i think that would be exciting i just
i'm not sure that really
would be possible in the way that it's
operated to date so i think i would
i would i would think about these kind
of
schools and then support for
uh farmer-led initiatives
in different places um
i don't know if that fits the bill and
i'm not that's kind of what i have in
mind
one of one of the grand challenges
before us um
thanks a lot rachel that was fantastic
you had a lot to the seminar series this
this semester and we thank you for your
presentation
and your participation in the in the
panel they're both great
thanks so much and thanks a lot for
everyone attending today
and and throughout the semester i hope
everyone has a decent next couple weeks
as we finish things up
be well thanks again bye-bye
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu